so young and hungry is very hilarious  show it's in its third season knock on  this particular season something  interesting might be happening yes  what's happening this okay all right  this is gonna be crazy so um we are we  are doing a show with this woman who is  fantastic I don't know if she can act  that's the thing that's gonna be really  scary I heard she can really cook but I  don't know she can act but we're doing a  whole show about her  the episode is fall the fact that you  were better than me cuz you know you  know I've already been looking at my  sides and such studying my script the  first time I ever I script my whole life  I've been begging to be in a cartoon  forever banegas mean on actual  television